what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
and so what I want to do here is run
over the story of the Punisher and
Doctor Strange facing off against the
Incredible Hulk spider-man Wolverine and
Ghost Rider now this is this is actually
a pretty short story and the reason why
is because this comes out of battle
world number one now for those of you
guys who are familiar with Secret Wars
bear with me for a second because a lot
of people are just now getting on to
Marvel Comics and so they're not really
sure about a lot of this stuff but when
Marvel wrote The Secret Wars event it
wasn't just the 1 through 9 series as it
was written by Jonathan Hickman in
addition to doing the last days which
detailed the final days of various
superheroes and characters Loki missed
Marvel so on and so forth what we also
got were a series of ancillary
publications there were most commonly
four issues in fact I don't really think
any any of them were more than four
issues but it was like ultimate the end
you had the planet Hulk storyline you
had a lot of these little ancillary
titles but a lot of them really just
dealt with these different domains
within battle world because when the
multiverse collapsed and Doctor Doom had
stolen the powers of the beyonders he
had quite literally just reached out
into what little fragments he could grab
from the multiverse and took those
different realities and threw them all
into one giant planet called battle
world in response he also created a
series of borders and will get a little
more into what those borders mean later
on but this basically gave Marvel the
opportunity to give us the battle world
series of comics which were you know
again for issues that ran over these
different iterations or these different
places in battle world itself now while
this was for issues and it was
considered a limited series there were
basically 1 shots not only that there
were really just two in one's and so it
was just a couple of short stories in
each individual issue of battle world
and again it was just designed to show
us the bigger picture here and so what
we do is we initially pick up with the
Punisher and the Punisher has actually
been fused with the spirit of Doctor
Strange and they both hail from the
earth 9 1 4 0 reality I think now this
this came out of a what-if story I think
was Marvel what if volume 2 issue number
24 this was a story where the villain
Dracula has succeeded in infect
the x-men and then basically defeating
everybody and the universe are everybody
in the world and turning them into
vampires now eventually wolverine was
able to escape and wolverine basically
over through dracula by killing him and
then wolverine became lord of the
vampires but the fact remains here that
in that universe the punisher was
successful in killing wolverine and dr.
strange his physical body had been
bitten so he basically left his body and
merged with the punisher frank castle
but this is just one of those instances
where by the punisher comes from a
reality that's no longer in existence
and he's the sole survivor and so what
were being told basically by joshua
williamson who's writing this is that in
this case where a singular being
survives from a dimension that's
basically destroyed it seems as though
dr. doom just grabs that being and
throws them into a section about a world
and this is when the borders come into
play when battle mode was created in
order to keep everything in order in
order to keep everything from basically
going insane dr. doom decreed that no
beings were allowed to leave their
borders and cross over into other
territories if they did that they would
be destroyed they would be hunted down
and they'd be thrown into the dead lands
which of course is the realm of
Annihilus um the age of Ultron robots
and the Marvel Zombies of course I have
a video on that that you'll find down in
the description but the fact remains
here that it seems as though somewhere
along the line the Punisher you know
again possessed by the spirit of dr.
strange had left his own realm had left
his area and began walking around or
traveling around another section about a
world which houses the Marvel 2099
universe and so because of this he had
been tasked or at least that four
individuals had been tasked by the
sheriff of battleworld Steven strange
the main Marvel Universe Stephen strange
to find Punisher and to kill him and
these four individuals are The
Incredible Hulk
Wolverine Ghost Rider and in spider-man
now were not told which version at least
were not initially told which version of
Ghost Rider this is but the fact remains
that they come from the realm of limbo
now again this is just one of the other
sections of battle world but limbo comes
from a a what-if story an alternate
universe story whereby the events of
Inferno had turned out differently when
the clone of Jean Grey Madeline Pryor
had made a pact with with demons from
the demonic realm of limbo and had
succeeded in taking over the world what
would that world have looked like that's
what that universe hails from and so
because of this these four beings are
effectively bounty hunters they do
carry out whatever it is that you know
whoever the contractor whatever is a
contractor is paying for and in this
instance Sheriff Steven strange is
paying for the capture of the Punisher
now we don't find out exactly what it is
that you know Steven strange was looking
for when he sent these guys you know to
go after the Punisher but the fact
remains though the Punisher himself was
able to take him out now this is one of
the coolest things here because with a
Punisher we come to expect you know with
Frank Castle that he's just gonna pull
out guns he's gonna shoot stuff he's
gonna blow things up but he doesn't have
his regular run of weapons here the
reason why is because he's possessed by
dr. strange which means he can now turn
around and he can just conjure weapons
as magical constructs and that's exactly
what he tides he conjures a couple of it
looks like ooze ease you know using the
way magical uses he conjures a couple of
ooze ease using the magic of dr. strange
and just unloads on everybody now
initially the idea is that he kills
Wolverine but they also succeeds in
killing Bruce Banner now the way he does
this is actually cool because we've
always asked the question lot of people
have asked the question what would
happen if the Incredible Hulk fought
against Doctor Strange how would that
work out we know that in Planet Hulk
that Stephen strange was defeated but
that was the Incredible Hulk in his
angriest form and so because of that we
can't take that as an absolute truth not
only that if it was classic Doctor
Strange she could just phase the
Incredible Hulk out of existence and
that would be it
but because these characters hail from
you know different realities it's
basically you know two two individuals
who have never met who hail from
different realities where things turned
out entirely different meeting one
another and so it comes you know comes
through a pretty interesting scenario
here but things turn out exactly the way
we would expect it to right you know
with the other Punisher invoking the
magic of Doctor Strange forcing the
incredible hope to return to his form of
Bruce Banner and then destroying him now
this does tell us a couple things in the
sense that the Incredible Hulk seems to
be indestructible in terms of the magic
of this version of Doctor Strange
possesses but because of the fact that
Bruce Banner is the weaker human form
it's easier to just make him Bruce
Banner and then kill him as opposed to
try to kill the Incredible Hulk so
Joshua Williamson doesn't really answer
this he just kind of leaves it to us to
figure out you know whether or not this
would be the case but the fact remains
here that he also turns his magic on
on the ghostrider now the reason why
this is kind of a big deal is because
with ghostrider again we're not told
which version this is we don't know if
it's you know an alternate reality
version of Robbie ray is that happens to
be wearing the coat of Johnny Blaze if
it is Johnny Blaze with this leather
jacket because that's what it looks like
it looks like Johnny Blaze but the fact
remains here you know that with with
Stephen strange invoking ice it's
basically a counter to Hellfire now this
is a big difference because in Marvel
Comics the fire of Ghost Rider what he
wields is the same kind of fire that
comes from the realm of Mephisto because
he's basically under contract from the
fifth step but the idea here is that
it's not your typical run-of-the-mill
fire that you see coming out of a butane
lighter now it is it's Hellfire it's for
all intents and purposes indestructible
or immutable by normal circumstances so
you couldn't run up on Ghost Rider and
spray him with a fire extinguisher and
expect him you know his scold us how
flaming it's immune to that kind of
stuff but it's not immune to the power
of Doctor Strange and so because of this
he basically freezes over the body of
Ghost Rider
and seems to kill him in the process at
the same time we also find that with
Wolverine in virtually any reality that
he's in his adamantium and his healing
factor are the two consistent factors
and because of this he cannot be killed
by normal means at least you know with
the Punisher using his various bullets
in someone he can't be killed in that
same former fashion and so after
freezing over Ghost Rider and then
destroying his body with a rocket the
Punisher is killed at least it seems is
always killed by Wolverine now of course
Wolverine stabs him to the chest with
adamantium and Doctor Strange of course
the spear pops up says hey conjure this
spell you'll be fine you'll be able to
live but Punisher doesn't want to live
and we'll find out why here at the end
of the story but the Punisher doesn't
want to keep on living anymore and so he
effectively creates a grenade out of the
magic that Doctor Strange has and in
return he allows himself to be destroyed
by basically blowing up and so what we
do is we immediately cut to the to the
castle of Victor Von Doom and we join
again Stephen strange as the as the
sheriff of Doom stat of the entirety of
battleworld and Wolverine says hey look
man like we you know the Punishers dead
I know we were supposed to bring him in
alive but he wanted to die he you know
destroyed himself with a grenade and the
questions asked why did you want
Punisher why'd you want Frank Castle in
the first place because remember they
couldn't see the spirit of Stephen
strange as far as they knew whenever
Frank Castle was
talking to Stephen strange spirit they
thought the Frank Castle was talking to
himself that he was just a crazy person
not only that we learn that the spirit
of Stephen strange basically imbued
itself to Wolverine now not only that
the spirit of Stephen strange says you
know you are going to do your best to
keep yourself alive thereby giving me a
body and if you don't I will make your
life hell so what this seems to indicate
is that the Punisher wasn't acting of
his own free will
the Punisher was acting according to the
will of Stephen strange and the Punisher
seems to have been put in a circumstance
whereby he was being tracked down by the
main you know the main Marvel of Stephen
strange and in the end he just ended up
killing himself we wouldn't have to live
through this life anymore but again this
is just a very very short story I mean
it's only like 10 pages long it's not
that lengthy at all but I invite you
guys to check out battleworld the the
four-issue limited series again they're
self contained you don't really need to
know everything about seeker wars all
you really have to know here is that the
multiverse collapsed dr. doom stole the
power of the beyonders he recreated or
brought backward realities he could and
then create a battle world and that's
really that's really all you need to
know and so it's a great way if anything
cuz a lot of you guys asked this how do
you segue into all-new all-different
marvel battle world is actually a really
good way to do that of course Secret
Wars works too because of the fact that
that's the main story about how
everything transitions from the previous
universe to Secret Wars to the
recreation of the earth-616 universe and
all-new all-different marvel but the
fact remains here that again this is a
pretty pretty interesting story and I
thought it'd be kind of enjoyable for
you guys hopefully you guys dug it if
you all are new here to a comic explain
make sure you hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob Korn again if you
did enjoy this then make sure you hit
the like button you don't drop a like
and leave a comment down below let me
know what you guys think and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you